the pursuit of pleasure will not bring
you happiness it will bring you
addiction for example that you know
drinking too much brings pleasure but
doesn't bring happiness is because it
doesn't actually bring enjoyment
enjoyment has a base in pleasure but it
adds two things it adds people and
memory anything that you do that brings
pleasure you do Alone look out I don't
know how to drink alcohol in a normal
way why because I started drinking
alcohol when I was 13 14 years old and
it was nothing but solitary pleasure and
I never learned how to make it into a
source of enjoyment that's the reason
that it became a problem is because I
was never able to use it in a
responsible way where it could enhance
my happiness you're going to hit the
button and hit the button and you're
going to become miserable doing that
until you break free and choose the
Divine path over the animal path till
you actually choose to do something that
is that mother nature is not urging you
to do and and that's the secret